[Music]
this week we've got boba toast frog
bikini and cat smuggler
that's me first show you smuggle cats
hmm no I believe don't put cats in your
[ __ ] oh yeah definitely not they
don't appreciate it
I love how cats look all the same like
it reminds oh they don't you take a back
oh please Nicky that was in Pasadena and
I saw a flier that said my cat is
missing and I was like well that's you
and ten thousand other cats look just
like that good luck [ __ ] alright well
first I was thinking about you David
that's true then I look like every fat
okay alright first story there's this
new craze in Singapore that's Doug has a
boba tea toast that sounds delicious
yeah so interesting that looks gross
wait what and though looks like they
forgot to smash the jelly into it looks
like bull boy inside pita bread yeah you
know the the toast the brick toast yeah
oh I like that yeah it's like a version
of that okay with boba inside of it with
filling interesting give me that chewy I
don't like both of you go with you to me
this is gross but I love boba but I
don't really know how I feel about that
I like what with you but that's just too
much on my outfit I like the balance of
the liquid I should look like insect
larva yeah goodbye
blueberry frickin pie I tried telling
myself is blueberry I'm like but Bennet
still starchy like boba and isn't warm
as the bolan warm you know just got me
back into boba I didn't get it I wasn't
eating that [ __ ] for like four years why
you don't like it I just got into
dollars just like give me straight T
like a old man I just want tea and
that's it
you're boring yep
and then she got into all this stuff and
I was like okay I'll just take some too
and I was like damn you know what
Bobo's gotten really good yeah people
evolved they're really even like this
shitty bubble pens are pretty decent
everything's evolved now because back in
the day I would only go to like one or
two spots because they were the ones
that day boba right I honestly think
that your guys's place sip has like the
best boat thank you better and I'm not
just saying that because I'm friends
with you and I like what's the name of
their place sip o Wayburn Street in
Westwood California next to UCLA you
guys could definitely check it out and
in the summer we're gonna be opening up
one in Chinatown and there's one in
Rowland Heights coming very soon and I
heard that their matcha is the highest
quality matcha it even gets with me it's
very good it's very nice very cool
okay how do you
beau-beau taste great or like what makes
it so boba when they first came because
I grew up on Bob as a kid he's an
ambassador Bowl because it's so it
wouldn't when I first came here I think
they're just trying to get it down like
really quick so they make a whole big
batch and then I've in the refrigerator
it gets kind of hard and sometimes you
buy it in if it gets like powdery so now
it's supposed to be like boba has its
own al dente feel to it and it's
supposed to be warm it's supposed to be
cooked a certain word slightly sweet and
adds flavor into the drink and a lot of
places do it like pretty good now
whereas before you would just go and
you're like oh that's [ __ ] day-old
boba but to get fresh Bo Bo you have to
constantly make it sell it and then make
it so I think that was a tedious thing
that a lot of the original like tapioca
Express yeah I haven't gotten to a place
where it was like the bubble was
terrible now so it's like it's weird
like when I see what it is for like
other places and they're like the
bubbles like [ __ ] really I don't know
what you're its boba what is it made out
of it's made out of the cassava plant
yeah so it comes it comes from a plant
what about because I like tapioca yeah
same this same thing oh is it yeah it's
all from that same from that cost of a
plant it should have the bounce of a
cocker spaniels ball sack
that's true I had a cocker spaniel
yeah cocker spaniels would have been the
same size yeah oh yeah that's the same
should have a recipe book that should be
tight how should your boba be I don't
have a cocker spaniel what maybe that
you all would do mantis mom I I know
what I don't like about this though as I
love boba but it's too much starch it's
like you got the bread already and then
you got the starchy boba there needs to
be a balance
yeah that's the Asian diet though that's
like just all that 90 percent starch
carbs and and in like 10% ingredients
they put proteins in there like tofu and
soy beans and finish like I had yakisoba
bread and I didn't like it that yakisoba
bread but we ran high nearly to gawky so
yeah put in bread that's a thing in
Japan and you know what else in
McDonald's over there they have potato
croquette burgers oh it's like a
deep-fried mashed potato that's breaded
with that katsu thing and they put it in
bread so they yeah they just put they
make it into a burger with like that War
Chester's tonkatsu sauce yes yeah that's
like it's just a carb sandwich yeah and
they do that - they it's pretty popular
when they have this like that that core
okay with just layers of bread on it I
like Keroppi karate hated the Frog yeah
but that's like a carb carb thing that's
so weird
who started that craze keroppi Singapore
and though wasn't a specific person oh
they don't really mention they're just
talking about how to breathe that's how
food is man people just be bite nothing
I know man why people got a steel like
that like can't they just be like oh
this was just give it credit like you
don't have to like give him money just
give him credit yeah after they made the
cronut every place produces cronuts
gnarly why you can't just let the person
that invented the cronut sell the chrony
am i weird for never liking cronuts no I
never liked her okay yeah I thought they
were wack it's one of those novel foods
that won't that didn't last right oh
thank goodness it's gone I mean it's
still around I guess but it's not people
don't crave it and go crazy over it I
still I liked it but I didn't like
more than a regular donut it wasn't like
oh [ __ ] I have this this shit's on
Krispy Kreme like Krispy Kreme forever
to me I saw this Cambodian place we
didn't make cronuts they made a docent
which was the ghetto is my daughter
Tulsa and you need gunshots up you want
some thoughts pop no but they do mention
this article that Benjamin Browns
is selling it in Singapore this pitocin
Djimon brown or 690 Singapore dollars
are five US dollars what I do like is
condensed milk and I could eat that
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's that [ __ ] go - Mexican
condensed milk I like that - it's brown
as hell they put that on the door is it
gold milk it's like um it's not even
caramel like the consistency of cocker
spaniel come I'll have a dog I have cat
you never checked off your cat well once
his penis was really small it's like a
Christmas light no I didn't I was like
the little Christmas lights all right
for our next story there's this woman
from Louisiana is 28 year old that she
grew up hunting and fishing around the
Bayou and her father taught her to never
race anything from an animal that's
amazing
always just use as much as you can and
so
fishbones jewelry everywhere you did say
frog [ __ ] swimsuit so one day she
went out hunting and she caught like
seven frogs the whole family it was a
really good mom the dad two kids off
yeah yeah she ended up skinning these
frogs which you created a bikini it may
be really soft that's pretty cool
frogs feel really nice end it I don't
know what it would feel like after stamp
when they're wet dude have you seen frog
skin before no it literally looks like
they're just taking like skinny jeans
off of a girl okay you ready
oh wow frogs in the Frog why why does
her skin look like that
she's skinned the Frog like and she
stuffed it she skinned it the way is
yeah she said it was a very delicate she
didn't even make it into like a triangle
she just kept the Frog shape now the
entire body of the Frog I was picturing
something totally beat you I was being
really really nice titties
I was like dad that's like just straight
up taxidermy frog yeah I thought she
made it like you know what he make a
leather jacket it doesn't look like a
cow and she kept it in the that's kind
of weird for me it's like she's trying
to make a statement yeah like this is
what your clothes are made of but she's
that she does have nicer titties are
nice let's scroll up again we're perfect
she were ish dish I mean is that a
lightsaber or what the [ __ ] is the
pitchfork no that's what they catch
frogs with oh really yeah so when you're
they'll go by in a boat yeah that thing
will Pierce frost oh it's like a sea
witch I wonder if she's out there in the
Bayou in her new bikini and catching
things like us goes down a little bit
more though thank you right there nice
just were the viewers I thought where I
thought she was weird you're not a dude
like yeah but look look how beautiful
those boobs are great
it looks like off of her body that's so
disgusting I thought she made a bikini I
didn't know she just stuffed the frogs
and I stuffed the Frog and I was
picturing like leopard print like you
know when there's like leopard print
bikini or whatever yeah that it was that
Souls like oh that's creative cuz when
you skin a frog right like
how do you keep it so [ __ ] stretchy
and it's like fish skin yeah she said it
was a duchess hardest book yeah long
difficult delicate process to make snake
skin stuff like snake skin purses they
don't keep the snake of [ __ ] - no I
know that's I I didn't imagine like a
taxidermy frog bikini yeah she says she
also covered it all in shellac SiC
Soviet so it could be waterproof so what
she actually go swim with she was
something them to eat so yeah a reaction
she did get the meat and everything rock
tastes good they do taste good yeah
they're pretty [ __ ] only eat the leg
you can't eat the body
I think the leg it just has the most
meat or some [ __ ] right so people just
throw away the other part is a lot of
organs corrugated skin yeah you usually
eat the muscle is what you're eating
yeah I think that's what I like it it's
like chicken wings
it's like though it's like the buffalo
wing Park it's like fish eat chicken
wings I like the texture of yeah I think
it's still cool though she's still using
all of the animals yeah I just threw me
off because I think we all pictured the
exact same thing and then when we saw it
it was like a 3d yeah that's why I was
telling her like close your eyes because
I was thinking the same when I read the
headline
and I saw the photo like she looks like
that one girl the [ __ ] it was at the
Fifth Element [ __ ] yeah yeah Lola yes
she's she's a contract someone that
knows how to sew bikinis yeah Milla
Jovovich and so as she's saying that she
will not be going into business creating
these bikinis because no one's gonna buy
them yeah make sense maybe I doubt that
there's a weirdness yes sure there are
very those are one of those like
handmade one items that can go for like
hundreds of thousands of dollars to some
like rich ass eccentric person that
needs to have it yeah so she says that
there's no reasonable way to like
there's no way to price this reasonably
because it's so much tedious work that
she just doesn't even want to go into
that so she's that um did she stuff more
does she's blowing up blowing them yeah
I thought it maybe as an inflatable
device so she could use it when she's
frog that person yeah but she said that
if anyone's interested on liking how to
do it oh she made it she's down to tell
you because she's like it's not it's not
like a secret how
how I did this that was like coolest
putting the work I think I could figure
it out she's more interested in her frog
recipes and what like if she lives off
the land like how is she cooking how is
she prepping like I want to see a bayou
Martha Stewart we lost these skills you
know like we just go to the grocery
store we buy [ __ ] like I love watching
these videos on YouTube like that [ __ ]
they're called catching Kooks
yeah you catch like a pig or some [ __ ]
wild wild deer or whatever and then they
do everything that's great time and then
they tell you teach you how to like cook
it all and then they eat it it's so
satisfying I don't know like I would
like to know how to learn that cuz I'm
like that'd be cool like in case somehow
I get lost in the woods well you should
probably just learn how to cook anything
in general no cuz she's in like cooking
at home she was simply stating cuz we
all know she doesn't like a cook let it
just finish her statement you skinny boy
you guys look skinny little [ __ ] you
guys want a cup if I go if I go I want
to go skydiving you guys will how about
stat on top of a building first yeah and
I mean it's like the dreams are robots
we could tell you that and emotionally
it doesn't affect but you guys would
still say it so that's a delicate little
flower is a flower but that's what the
site that's like what I said hey I'm
probably gonna run a mile to a bar said
we'll watch you just [ __ ] get up
first yeah
once you walk to the car for once yeah
when you weren't here when you were
walking here bar was all like no guys
he's doing really good and I'm proud of
him but that's not what he texted me
that's what we do we turn the cameras
off like boost tip up motivator and then
we trauma care down on the cab open
though that everyone every friend that
meets her now talk [ __ ] to her like that
is that cool exactly I can't handle
I'm not strong like it's a heart
stronger skin like you just get the girl
I can't be more done'
you're not like cooking i hate it you
hate it fun has to be fun yeah if
there's a link with Xena pop it in the
microwave it's a novelty I like cooking
man like cooking it you like cooking no
I like cooking I was being Tiffany right
now the items only like yeah that link I
do like cooking if it's you just said
you hate it I know but I'm explaining
why I hate it so I hate cooking when I
have to just create it on my own cuz I'm
not I don't like food period what I
would not survive it how do you not like
food that's like I don't like breathing
I just eat to survive like ya
inconvenience that you busy sustenance
I'm inconvenient I get inconvenient but
when you eat something delicious it
doesn't please you like you don't go oh
yeah but all the delicious oh yes health
before you that's why it sucks no that's
what that I think that's the reward for
are these for me is when I cook
something and I was imagining this this
flavor and when I put it in my mouth I'm
like that's what I've been [ __ ] if I
cook something I want to eat then when I
eat I'm like yes is what I wanted but I
don't want to eat it anymore because I'm
so tired from cooking it so when yeah
[Laughter]
I'm like eating the ingredients along
the way because I'm so hungry
everything's laid out for me and like
like you know recipes I can you like all
the yeah she doesn't have the building
blocks so it's almost like saying like
you have these expectations of painting
the [ __ ] Mona Lisa right but then you
don't even know how to finger paint yeah
exactly when you get there it's just
frustrating because you don't know the
building blocks yeah and I think for I
think I don't know how people learn to
cook but there's so much experimenting
that goes behind it some mistakes yeah
and then you eat your mistakes and
you're like whatever but if you don't go
over it get over that hurdle
then you're not gonna enjoy it at all do
you like cooking cereal yeah so you know
how to cook cereal yes how do you cook
your cereal
I first pour the cereal and then I pour
the milk that's the right way though the
real way you pour the cereal right and
it make sure it's nice and even at the
balls you can't have it lumpy then you
gotta get the milk and you do it and
like a cinnamon cinnamon roll like that
all the milk in the know I want to
separate the crunch from the men thank
you and then I go like this I like
suppressing it right when it's half
crunchy has path soft and then right
before you're about to finish with that
cereal milk you get more so you put in
their new double flavor now I don't like
warm milk with my cereal no I even put
ice in my cereal sometimes because I
like it gets doping you're just you're
basically just adjusting everything to
what you like yeah do you think you
could do better than what it's supposed
to be I didn't know how to cook at all
and that's why I started cooking on my
channel like I just sort of vlogging
myself cooked like four years ago and it
became a thing because other people were
like I was too scared to start cooking
it's a Tuesday come check me out but um
but yeah like I didn't know you're
supposed to prep ingredients before you
started cooking so I was trying to do it
like while we were yeah and then there's
all these like terms like take a potato
masher I'm like what the [ __ ] is a
potato mash this is a pastry consoles
that I had no idea existed and then
they're like um I hate when the recipe
goes add as much of this ingredient to
your taste like I don't know what the
[ __ ] this tastes like
I know but that's true though that's why
it like I always tell people if you're
gonna cook something you have to eat it
first
so don't don't just be cooking [ __ ]
off of sight go into a restaurant order
it eat it and then cook it yeah it could
be enough recipes and then you know what
you like and then you could kind of
experiment true alright for our last
story here there was this cat that got
caught you're gonna love his story it
was cats I got caught smuggling cell
phone into a prison in Costa Rica that's
what you should be a cat person I know
you could train cats you could train
anything yeah just don't like you to be
Chinese you know when you watch movies
with animals they're all trained
were they stuffing cellphones up of cat
babies no no so this is the only still
image I could get because there's like a
video of them getting it but I don't
even know gray the gray ones are so
smart that cat to the floor do the
[ __ ] floor yeah so they caught this
cat and apparently it was really hard to
catch his cat so this cat has been
spotted once before but they couldn't
catch this cat first off that's too fast
because apparently this prison they have
a lot of feelings there and so they
finally caught this one and they they
saw that there was a little sac attached
to it and so they cut it open and they
found a cell phone a charge even like
the hair by the other earbud thing and
then the bat and extra battery is there
a backpack like a baby cat backpack yeah
that's just like I got all stack it was
in all I imagine like a little JanSport
and they said that they finally caught
the cat but after they they cut the cell
phone and everything this fool just ran
away and it'll be back but he wouldn't
get caught like he just didn't like
anyone touching him and then so now he
was heading so I guess there was like
three cell blocks he was heading to the
last one so they at least know that it's
someone in that cell block but there's
like 120 prisoners there so everyone's a
suspect right now yeah yeah and no one's
errata so they're not gonna say okay no
snitch though he's like I'm out yeah so
what they're speculating here is that
one of the prisoners must have gotten
the cat cuz there's a lot of cats at the
prison because must have gotten the cat
train the
cat sent the cat out communicator compel
with someone on the outside to put a
cell phone on the cat and then now that
cats been smuggling phones in you
finally caught the boob then you got
away of course was that iPhone no cats
are really hard to catch you guys ever
tried catching a Katherine yeah they're
so slippery dude like one or two in my
life plus they can claw you yeah
do any of your cats like taking baths um
I'm never I don't make them do that cuz
I don't like wet cats because they don't
like dry off very easily so the only
time I've ever given them a bath is when
they had fleas one time um and I would
say they don't like it but once they're
in the water they're pretty calm like
they don't try to like scramble out like
that as long as I'm like they're in the
water with them they're just kind of
like they'll deal with it it's inhumane
to declaw okay yes yes well it's like
cutting off your fingers yes it's not
it's not nice but you do I trim the
claws yeah you can cut there can cut
their claws like their fingernails but
if you do claw them it's like it's like
they have no fingers as my friend had a
cat that was like declawed declawed as
[ __ ] not well a lot of people didn't
know before it's like there's we first
got our cats I told Casey I'm like oh
maybe she did climb and he told me that
and I was like oh my gosh I did not yeah
yeah a lot of people don't know a lot of
people in the Midwest still do it
because they I don't know if they don't
get scratched yeah that's just always a
claw
yeah they scratch everything like I
think like when you think of Kappa and
you press one of the pads in the clock
on them you like Wolverine what you go
over what you can do instead of decline
you if they have caps that you can have
them put on I bought some of this luck
oh just give them cat mints like the dog
shoes yeah there's a new trend out where
they have dogs where like a full
bodysuit so it prevents the shedding oh
so it helps with that what doesn't
prevent it but it helps with it and then
when you take it off it all the fur gets
stuck brush your dog's before
[Music]